all structures in the body function
together to maintain
homeostasis a process by which the body
maintains its internal environment in
response to the external environment
examples of how the body maintains
homeostasis include metabolism of drugs
and toxins in the
liver regulation of water and solutes in
the blood by the
kidneys regulation of blood glucose by
the
pancreas another homeostatic process
Thermo regulation is the maintenance of
normal body
temperature if the body's skin or core
temperature drops thermal receptors in
the skin or internal
organs send impulses
to the
hypothalamus which acts as the body's
thermostat the
hypothalamus responds through the
sympathetic nervous system by
constricting blood vessels in the
skin Vaso constriction diverts blood
away from the skin and extremities to
the warmer interior of the body to
prevent further loss of heat to the
surroundings and prevent the body's core
temperature from dropping
further erector Pei muscles contract
causing pilo erections in which hair
follicles stand up in an attempt to trap
warm air next to the
skin a continued drop in temperature
prompts the
hypothalamus to send impulses that
elicit a shivering reflex in skeletal
muscles generating additional heat to
increase body
temperature if the body skin or core
temperature
increases thermal receptors in the skin
or internal organs prompt the
hypothalamus to Halt sympathetic
stimulation of blood vessels in the skin
the vessels dilate and allow warm blood
to distribute heat through the
skin erector Pei muscles relax and hair
follicles lie flat against the skin
sweat glands produce sweat allowing heat
loss through
evaporation the stimulus or decrease in
body temperature causes the brain to act
as a thermostat and dissipate Heat
throughout the body once normal
temperature is reached the thermostat
shuts off these examples of the body's
response to counteract stimuli are
called negative feedback loops which
allows the body to maintain
homeostasis